welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka spoil and King
and the finale of the outsider is
finally here the HBO show has been an
incredible ride the last 10 weeks an
episode ten has a hell of a lot to
unpack from it throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down all of
the ins and outs of the finale it's
ending the post-credits scene and where
things could be going in the future
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want anything ruined then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
to never miss a breakdown and please
drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the video
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our ending
explained of the outsider episode 10
picks up immediately after the shootout
that began last week's cliffhanger Alec
is dead and everyone else is in the
crosshairs of a military trained
marksman so it looks like they could be
going on the highway to heaven
and I'm not talking about the best
chicken in 200 miles that joke didn't
really work does it
Howie called in seal arrived and the
latter returns fire shouts Max Beesley
as well who plays seal and like my
breakdown of the episode last week I'm
sorry you had to go out like that and I
love you he Howie a nanny are killed and
it's a really devastating scene that
holds no punches watching these
characters die one after the other feels
worse than the red wedding on Game of
Thrones and it's going to be a lot of
grief and despair left from all of this
I'll discuss how this may play a part
later if there's a season two but yeah
that's just something to bear in mind at
the moment Holly put herself in Jack's
sights but he lowers his weapon after
being reminded that he's only going one
way after this that is straight to hell
I think he also remembers that Holly did
genuinely want to help him earlier in
the season and he relinquishes control
before getting his comeuppance
I was predicted last week the snake
bites him which ends the fight and all
that are left standing a sob low Ralph
Claude and Holly Jax Tom Wilson to the
area and he's been bitten several times
in the face by the snake so he now looks
like the outsider mid-transformation he
points the way to the bear cave and they
slowly make their way through
discovering caucuses and eventually elk
cuoco they see that he took the stairs
precautious Lee showing that he's scared
of falling and therefore he can be
killed they passed several of the
landmarks from last week's episode and
it's a very intense scene that uses
multiple exposures to overlay the beast
with that journey into the depths of
Hell al cuoco actually helps to guide
them which showcases the psychological
aspect of the character it wants to be
found
but in guiding them it will make them
think that it has the upper hand already
and thus it doesn't mind allowing them
to come face to face with it the Beast
looks completely like cord now because
of the 27 day transformation cycle
coming to an end and it must now choose
another face it has purposely chosen
this location because of the nature of
the collapse last week which was caused
by the search party showing for the boys
though they could instantly shoot it
they are already aware of the cave-in
and have been reminded by the names of
the dead Bolton's that it's a bad idea
so it's fair enough that they're taking
it easy in terms of their weapons they
actually have a conversation with al
cuoco who enforces the notion that the
greatest trick the devil ever pulled was
convincing the world that he didn't
exist
al cuoco has evaded the law for
centuries because people simply won't
believe in it holly was the only one to
and thus it was finally caught during
the exchange of cuoco hints at the idea
that there may be more than just one out
there and no it hasn't encountered any
of its other kind it does know that they
exist Stephen King's work all tends to
be linked in some way and this could be
a nod to Pennywise the true knot or some
of the other creatures that he's created
earlier in the season Alec did stay that
when he was a young boy he got lost in
the woods and he heard something calling
his name so we do know that should the
show go beyond this season that there
are other avenues in which they can
travel al cuoco also pays lip service to
the glow that fields him from grief it
gives him energy and he feeds upon it
and thus it is possible that if the
deaths of those in the caves from 40
years still provide him with a power
that the bodies of those murdered
outside could also Holly asks why
children and the creature applies with
because they taste the sweetest we did
say in Episode a that due to the comment
on one of the victims cancers that al
cuca would probably eat younger people
as they're less likely to have it but
maybe maybe the guy just likes the taste
this sets ralph off as we know he has
lost a child himself and he says that al
cuoco
nowhere to go and that the authorities
will arrive soon the monster seems to be
accepting of this but like he says he
needs to eat and the pair could make a
great Last Supper Claude arrives with
the shotgun and Hann staring at his
mirror image and he wants to get revenge
for the death of his brother despite
being warned not to fire he still does
it anyway
I'll cuoco inhales almost accepting of
its fate and this is because of the
psychic link that it has with Claude
after the blast echoes throughout the
caber collapses and they hide out
missing the worst of it
Halle stabs I'll could go through the
chest just to make sure it's dead and
this differs from the source material as
in that Holly hits the creature over the
head with a happy slapper which is the
sock full of balls she also used this
weapon in the Stephen King story mr.
Mercedes but as that hasn't been set up
here I can't see why they changed it
slightly in case you don't know mr.
Mercedes is actually TV show as well and
though the cast and creative team behind
it are different if you if you want a
nice distraction whilst you wait for the
second season of The Outsider yeah I
definitely recommend checking it out
it's three seasons deep and also centers
around Halle Gibney so go check it out
after this upon exiting the cave ralph
comes face to face with the specter of
his dead son and he goes back to hell
cuoco to see it playing opossum I'm
gonna talk about whether this was
actually Derek or if it was just a
vision by ilkook or later but personally
I think it was the latter
I'll cuoco we'll just wait and know
ralph could bring people to see it
collect DNA samples and expose it to the
world it's for the best and no one ever
knows that it existed we see it change
to Terry who I only realized in this
episode Holly doesn't know about Tracy
Powell and Maria and it slowly begins to
cycle back through the chain showing who
it framed ralph smashes its head in with
a rock
thus apparently killing it once and for
all you also see the green hoodie in the
rubble at the creature war between
transformations showing that it could
potentially have another plan after this
outside Holly feels guilt over bringing
Andy out there but Ralph talks her out
of it we cut to the DA reviewing the
footage of teryan Claude and he gets a
phone call from sob low sob Lowe tells
him that there was a rogue shooter that
was one of their own and the DA
immediately writes down Jack before he
been hearing it was him
this shows that he will likely believe
whatever he's told due to his prized
suspicions sob low tells him that Jack
was the accomplice of the child killer
that's been operating in the area and
says that though they gunned the format'
down the real threat got away therefore
they will not really investigate the
cave but Terry's name will be cleared
and the manhunt will remain at large
though we already know that justice has
been served
Quadra hisses his story and remakes his
statement on identifying Terry is being
covered in blood they line everything up
and make sure that all bases are covered
Ralph says that he thought the whole
thing would turn out to be BS but it
wasn't which showcases his Auk
throughout the season while he breaks
down over Andy and it's one of the
saddest moments in the series this fall
Ralph calls Jeanne to fill her in on the
cover-up and she visits glory and the
two agree to never mention ilkook Oh
Jeanne triumphantly sets the chair
alight the hell cuoco sat in and though
several lives were destroyed in the
series at least there was justice and
closure for the families the DA meets
with glory and as we guessed last week
he tells her that things have changed in
the case and that Terry has been
discarded as a suspect in the homicide
he will hold a press conference to
announce that the charges are being
dropped and that the investigation will
remain ongoing it's a big apology that
finally spares Gloriana two daughters of
the accusations that they would have
faced in regards the case
Holly packs up her things and goes to
leave and Ralph tells her that he
wouldn't mind teaming up with her again
should the right case pop up she says
that she believed in al cuoco because an
outsider knows an outsider now why this
is interesting is because this entire
series we believe that al cuoco is the
outsider
however this cements that it is actually
Holly which the tile was about whilst I
can see some disagreeing with that
notion especially my wife who said I'd
be stupid if I put that in the video I
did wonder how they would continue the
show after the death of L cuoco it's
because it was never really centered
around that rather it focused on Holly
learning of the beast and also the
supernatural things that exist in the
world that will open the door for
further investigations ralph asks what
else is out there and she shrugs saying
that she doesn't know this is important
because almost every other question in
the series Polly has had an answer for
whether its lines from movies that she
hasn't seen calm
makes and models or the hit parade for
the last 100 years Holly knows it all
finally she's found something she's in
sure of showing that there is so much
more out there for her to learn and
she's actually traveling into unmarked
territory quad moves into the house and
he gets his funeral and Holly lights
candles and remembrance at Derek's grave
Ralph tells jeannie that he saw their
son and that he said that he needed to
let him go
no Ralph believed that this was ELQ ago
and never actually took it as that for a
number of reasons firstly our cuccos
nightmares always came with torturous
messages that tormented those who
received them juxtaposing this Dericks
was a hopeful one that counted this al
cuoco also fed on grief whereas Derek
told Ralph to free himself of this which
seemed like a positive thing for the
character the two now fully believe in
the other side and that they will get to
see this sin again one day and they
placed their roses on the stone as they
leave we catch a glimpse of Frankie
Peterson's grave which started this
whole thing off the show ends but it's
not done yet and it actually has a
mid-credits scene that centers on Holly
she's clearly haunted by Jack and he
appears behind there for a brief second
showing that something is psychically
out there tormenting her she checks the
back of a neck but isn't affected and
therefore Ally she's out the clear for
that after googling Frankie Peterson she
sees that Terry's name has been cleared
as she sits and listening to the radio
we can also see that there's a scratch
on her home now there's an awful lot to
take from this scene and firstly the
song on the radio is Washington Square B
cast your mind back to episode 8 Ralph
told her that when his mother was dying
he ran to get her her favorite song in
order to play it as she passed away he
didn't hear it anymore until his son was
born and though he said this entire
thing was an anecdote it did seem like
the truth the song that we hear at the
end is Washington Square which is also
the song that Ralph heard and now that
we no longer believe in coincidences
this has been placed here for a reason
to show the importance in the moment now
to me the red scratch shows that al
cuoco is intending on Holly becoming its
next victim though he appeared to die in
the finale we also saw that he's
extremely difficult to kill and if a
knife through the heart shotgun blasts
and massive rock impaling him didn't
finish him off then I can't see a rock
to the head
either we know that there's a strong
sense of death in the cave and that
there's a pile of murdered bodies
outside of it which could be providing
fuel for the character personally I
believe that once al cuoco dies it does
move into its more psychic astral form
that we also saw throughout the season
it could have allowed Ralph to leave the
cave but wondering if it was really dead
but instead it showed him images of
ghosts to make him return this could be
because it needed him to believe that he
had finally killed it so that he could
lay low and then go out for more victims
as Holly knows who it is she is very
dangerous and thus it will need to get
her out of the way so it could be
framing her to take her out of the
picture all of those that knew about it
covered up its demise and thus it will
be free to operate once more it has
already started filling her head with
visions of Jack and we know from core
that likes to get inside its victim's
head so I can't see this being in
habbaniyah for a second season
showrunner Richard price recently told
indieWIRE that he was already working on
a follow-up and it's there of HBO want
one if al cuoco is really dead then yeah
this Kurt was probably just caused in
the cave-in however that doesn't mean
that out of the woods completely as we
know from Alex story and the other
victim that was shown to the DA there
exists more than just out cuoco and I
think going forward Holly and Ralph will
be seeing one another a lot sooner than
they think overall there are a lot of
avenues to take it but personally I
think of cuoco itself may be returning
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on episode 10 and what you've
thought this season overall comment
below and let me know and I just want to
say thank you for sticking with me
through the series I've had a blast
breaking this down and I hope you've
enjoyed watching the videos as much as
I've had making them it's been great
chatting with you in the comments and
thank you for all of the support you
enjoyed the video then please drop a
thumbs up and if you missed any of the
episodes that make sure you check them
out in the playlist at the end we're
going to be covering Westworld as of
next week so hopefully you want to stick
around for that too as i've got a
feeling it's gonna be something special
you want to support the challenge get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below you can
also come chat to us on our discord
server or a definition whitey on Twitter
every month on the 15th we give away
free blu-rays and all you have to do to
being with a chance of winning
infinitely sagar box says it's leave a
like and subscribe with notifications on
this that will be shipped out from then
to ever gets the prize and best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace